SOREN GJESSE: Hello.
My name is Soren Gjesse and
I work on the Dart team.
I want to show you why Dart is
a great language for building
applications for the cloud.
Dart is a new platform for
scalable web application
engineering.
And Dart runs in modern web
browsers and on the server.
This provides a
great opportunity
to build web applications
using the same language
for both client and server,
and to utilize the services
provided by the
Google Cloud Platform.
Today, I'd like to
show you how easy it
is to run your Dart code
in Google's data centers,
use App Engine Managed VMs.
That is now a supported
language on App Engine.
App Engine scales automatically
as your application
gets more and more popular.
App Engine Managed VMs combine
the power of App Engine
with the flexibility of
running on a general server.
It lets you combine the total
control of freedom of computing
and VMs with the auto-management
capabilities of App Engine.
Because you're
running in a VM, you
can install any
additional software.
And there are no
restrictions on how
the Dart server can
use the machine.
Even accessing your
favorite C library
using a native
extension is possible.
App Engine Managed VM
support local development.
Your development tests locally.
And when you're ready to
deploy, the deployment process
make sure that the
exact same code
will run in the
Google data center.
To get started, you
only need a few things.
You need the Google Cloud SDK,
which includes a gcloud command
line tool.
And you need the latest version
of the Dart SDK and the Dart
Editor.
The process is all well
documented on the Dart website,
dartlang.org.
Getting started is easy.
A basic HTTP server application
is just a few lines of code.
Import the Dart
App Engine package,
start the server
application running,
and handle HTTP
requests as you already
do with the Dart I/O library.
If you already have a server
application written in Dart,
moving it to App
Engine only requires
changing a few lines of code.
You can run this code locally
using the gcloud app run
command.
And when you're happy
with your application,
deploy it by just running the
gcloud app deploy command.
This site is providing
an HTTP server.
The App Engine package provide
APIs to Google Cloud Services.
The initial set of
APIs provided are
for accessing Cloud datastore,
Memcache, Users API,
and for Logging.
Let's look at the
Cloud datastore.
The Google Cloud datastore
is a fully managed schemaless
database for storing
non-relational data.
Being a schemaless database,
it lets you store and entities
having a set of
named properties.
To give your app
maximum flexibility,
we provide two APIs.
There's a low level
API, which allows
you to work with
datastore entities
directly as key value map.
On top of this, we've
added a mapping layer.
This makes it possible to store
concrete instances of data
updates with just a
few simple annotations
to indicate how your
instance properties should
map to datastore properties.
Let me show you how
simple it is to store
an update into the datastore.
First, you need to model
how the update is stored.
Let's look at this
simple person class.
We want to store the two
properties, name and age.
The class defines properties
and extends model.
Then the actual description
of how this object maps
to the datastore
is described using
a subclass of model description.
Note, this defines the
types used in the datastore.
It can also be used to define
additional information,
like whether the
property is mandatory
and whether it should be
indexed in the datastore.
With this model
description in place,
the model class is annotated
with the description,
and the class
definitions are all set.
Now storing objects
into the data store
is as simple as creating
a number of instances.
Here, we create two
instances, George and Sarah.
And then we call the
data store commit method
to actually store these
instances into the data store.
Here we use a Dart
asynchronous programming model.
The future return
from commit completes
when the commit
operation has finished.
If you're familiar with the
App Engine Python NDB Datastore
API, this probably
looks familiar to you.
This is all open source.
The code is developed
on GitHub and is
available as a Dart package
using the Dart package manager,
pub.dartlang.org.
Now let's take advantage
of code-sharing.
When you use Dart both in
the client and on the server,
your front end and
backend can share code.
This is great, because this code
only has to be written once.
For example, say your client
and server communicating
using a JSON-based protocol.
The associated data
objects and serialization
and deserialization code
is needed on both sides.
Having the updates used
the communication defined
in a shared library ensures that
both sides share the same code.
There are many other
advantages to sharing code
on client and server, like not
having to rewrite validation
logic in different languages.
With that on both
client and server,
this validation
logic can be shared.
How about the case when an
application needs to work
offline?
In this case, large
part of the code
that is running on
the server needs
to be available on the client.
When using the same language
in both client and server,
this becomes easier.
The code only needs
to be written once
and will always be in sync.
These are simple examples.
A new app, you can find
even better uses of this.
Well, this is just
the beginning.
We are going to evolve our
Dart support for Google cloud.
On the API side, there
are still a number
of popular App
Engine APIs missing.
And we will be
adding more of these.
Another important
thing we're working on
is improving Dart access
to Google Cloud Services
in general.
Most services, like
Google datastore,
is available on most platforms.
It's available Google
Compute Engine.
It's available on
your own server,
on other cloud provider service,
and even in the browser.
We would also be working
on making the Google Cloud
Services available in
all these platforms,
making your Dart code equally
valuable across platforms.
With this information,
I hope you're
dying to get started
developing you're
Dart application
for Google Cloud.
Visit dartlang.org to find
more information on how to get
started and start building
your Dart application
in the cloud today.